I mentioned this I mentioned this last
night this week a lot of Network shows
are going to return to the air after a
two-week break because of the Olympics
one of those shows coming back tonight
is NBC's this is us okay this thing is a
huge ratings hit people love this show
yeah yeah and I was thinking about it
and it's clear because of the success of
that show that people love searing
family drama so I was thinking why not
add that to our show okay that I mean
that's what people want millions of
people are gonna tune in if we do that
it's bound to work I say we do it now
[Applause]
[Music]
let's set this before but there is
nothing and I mean nothing more
important than family oh yeah
well if family is so important to you
why haven't you visited dad he asked for
you every day but you're out there in
Hollywood doing cocaine off a Johnny
Galecki 's neck and eatin pizza with LL
Cool J I work hard for this family and I
deserve some meat on you don't just have
anything especially our respect and
while Dad takes some of his last breaths
you haven't even visited once strategist
I don't have time to travel you are 20
feet away you just left me here to care
for him and didn't want to deal with it
that's no way to treat your own sister
you have a lot of nerve laying the guilt
on me about dad when not once not once
have you acknowledged that I'm the only
one taking care of mom oh wow
Conan I don't know how to tell you this
but that's not mom this isn't our mom
thanks for the free vicodin sucker
you watched her I hated both of you
[Music]
[Applause]
mrs. Conan knew this spring on TV news
Andy rector everybody is
he's that Andy
you